say hi it's okay your favorite thing
about the channel okay guys what's your
favorite thing about the channel tick
and you over Wong
I mean have myself there's nothing where
you want I'm doing a thing here look
there thank you
what's your name Matthew Matthew what's
your favorite thing about the channel um
what do you buy the delicious taste is
bright today
yeah
well what's your name happy three what's
your favorite thing about the channel
you me someone's already said that you
guys say anything
honk-honk crafted me the sward and then
shall defeat you I shall turn you off
what's your favorite things about the
chance well that your sex is a painting
person and when I would when I was
instead I would watch your videos and
you would make me laugh and be all thank
you
one of my favorite
I also because you're not afraid oh
you're not afraid to show your feelings
you've got wisdom beyond her years Thank
You say bye
this is Ultron what's your favorite
thing about me and how great I am
you just demonstrate the best and the
worst of humanity and how to function
like one minute you're having deep
discussions and yet the next thing you
know you can chill bring it so Kenya and
I practical area that's tea
okay all right thank you well I'm both
the best and worst of humanity whoo I'm
Ultron that is Homer hey please don't
kill me take them first please anything
but me say mark relax
much amusement so I think I want to live
thank you very much have a good Morgan
what's your name
Jay today I'm Angie and we're fighting
ha
fight me quite harder I can't imagine
ninja star harder kill me kill me kill
me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill
me
I feel dirty oh my gosh
Oh God we feel like Efron dick in an end
you've killed ah then I went my line got
so long rallying people fighting the
security shut me down so I had literally
had to stand here for the past like hour
with this sign on my head and decide and
she's brown and we